l'archipel de la rivière des mille îles
huguette larochelle le contemple tous
les jours et se battre pour sa
protection n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille parce qu'un inconnu l'espoir
et le désespoir parce qu'on nous a fait
des promesses qu'il n'a pas tenues la
réserve faunique ce sanctuaire où l'on
retrouve les deux tiers des espèces de
la faune québécoise pourrait voir sa
superficie x 20 qu'on veut connecter
tous ces espaces nok soit des berges des
îles des terrains à proximité de la
rivière pour pouvoir les aménager les
mettre en valeur donc donner accès aux
citoyens avant descente y avoir des des
embarcations à bord des navettes viable
concrètement ça veut donc dire rendre
accessibles toutes les zones en verre
sur cette carte on passerait de 26 à 550
hectares chacun avec beaucoup d
enthousiasme un aussi grand parc naturel
au milieu d'une métropole l'organisme
éco-nature y pense depuis 12 ans on
essaie un plein en organiser donc j'ai
pressé en semi naturels sont immenses on
a beaucoup de dégradations de perte
d'habitat huguette elle réfléchit à
l'impact réel que cela pourra avoir sur
son joyau qu'est ce que ça peut changer
mais il va falloir en prendre soin parce
que jusqu'à maintenant personne n'a
franchement ça va nous permettre entre
autres d'avoir des sources de
financement nationales pour avoir des
gaffes récit qui vont protéger les sites
inspecter le site
l'année dernière laval acheté deux
grandes îles mais il en reste encore
plusieurs et le candidat de l'opposition
un plan nous allons réserver
annuellement 10 % des surplus de la
ville à un fonds en vain pour permettre
des acquisitions il s'engage notamment à
acheter la majeure partie de l'île
gagnon où un projet de centre de
villégiature a suscité beaucoup de
grogne l'année dernière pour agrandir la
réserve faunique c'est le ministère des
forêts qui devra trancher ici mathieu
prost radio-canada laval